a busy city street Maya with her guide
dog
good boy steady Aaron Lauridsen
lighthouse San Francisco we want to
explore our world in the same ways that
everybody else wants to explore their
world outdoor donning a headset
soundscape fills in a lot of the mental
map as you move it makes it effortless
and seamless to know what's around you
because it's designed such that you can
just put it in your pocket and go Maya
using soundscape walking with Alex yes
DSW shoe warehouse cool things happening
around town here when I'm with other
people I'm able to gather a lot of the
same information my sighted friends or
family are getting from the signage
around me and with that I'm able to
participate in hey look what's over
there oh the signal is showing up here
as well which is one of my favorite
stores oh really yeah
those moments that don't usually happen
for me in my life David walking in the
park using the technology is relatively
easy you have to still concentrate on
listening for obstacles but you then get
used to the chatter in the background
and you can pick out suddenly something
that's of interest to you
Shona around town it was great tell me
all the different shops as they pass
which is lovely in the different street
names as well quite often I don't know
you know which Street split approaching
intersection vastly goes routes Maya
touching phone screen the beacon has
been helpful in approaching different
addresses and places in busier areas
from extended pointing with her phone
great so let's just set off that way
okay passing through an open market it's
been a unique experience to work with
the soundscape team they have been so
transparent forthcoming open to feedback
it's been a really dynamic relationship
you have blind people on your team
you're working deeply with agencies like
lighthouse and reaching out and engaging
with blind people in different places
and from different backgrounds and
really making sure that what's being
created is aligned with the needs of the
community entering the store logo of
guide dogs UK logo of lighthouse San
Francisco Microsoft empowering every
person to achieve more